E
SAFELY.
BUT UNDER THIS INCOMPETENT
PRESIDENT, I FRANKLY JUST FEAR
THE WORST.
JOINING US NOW U.S. ARMY COMBAT
VETERAN.
HE RESCUED AMERICANS FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
ALSO, CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE
FROM FLORIDA CORY MILLS IS WITH
US AT AN UNDISCLOSED LOCATION
OUTSIDE OF AFGHANISTAN.
CORY, FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO
SAY THIS TO YOU AND APPARENTLY
SOMEONE TOLD ME JUST BEFORE THE
SHOW TIME PEOPLE ARE CRITICIZING
ME FOR SAYING THIS ON MY RADIO
SHOW.
THE FACT THAT YOU RETIRED
SPECIAL OPS GUYS ARE WILLING TO
PUT YOURSELF BEHIND ENEMY LINES
TO SAVE AMERICANS, I AM IN ALL
OF THE COURAGE AND COMMITMENT
AND THE LOVE OF COUNTRY THAT
YOU ARE SHOWING.
I WISH OUR PRESIDENT SHARED THAT
LOVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS.
I HOPE WE CAN HELP YOU IN THESE
EFFORTS.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS, THEY ARE
NOW TAKING CREDIT FOR WHAT YOU
HAVE DONE.
YOU HAVE A PRETTY STRONG
RESPONSE TO THAT.
>> WELL, FIRST OFF, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME, SEAN.
I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU HAVE TO
SAY.
I WAS REALLY NO LEADER BUT IT
THERE WAS NO LEADER WHEN IT CAME
TO OUR TEAM.
WE ARE A GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH SPECIAL SKILL SETS AND
BACKGROUNDS.
I WAS AN HONOR TO BE A MEMBER OF
THAT TEAM TO FACILITATE THE
OPERATION THAT WENT ON TO SAVE
THIS FAMILY BUT YOU ARE EXACTLY
RIGHT, SEAN.
IF THE ADMINISTRATION HAD DONE
WHAT IT WAS SUPPOSED TO DO, IT
WOULD NOT BE NECESSARY FOR GUYS
LIKE MYSELF OR BRAVE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE GUYS ON THEIR TEAM WHO
SPEAK FIVE LANGUAGES.
WE HAVE GUYS WHO SPENT DECADES
IN SPECIAL OPERATIONS.
FORTUNATELY, WE ARE ABLE TO
RESCUE THIS MOTHER AND THREE
CHILDREN, BUT AGAIN, NO SINGLE
AMERICAN SHOULD HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND.
THERE ARE MORE AMERICAN STILL
BEHIND THE LINES.
WE FOUND SOME GREAT COORDINATION
WHEN IT CAME TO THE LOCAL U.S.
STATE DEPARTMENT EFFORTS AND THE
COUNTRY TO GET THEM OUT.
WHEN IT CAME TO TAKING FULL
CREDIT, IT IS JUST UNTRUE.
>> Sean: SO TELL ME ABOUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOU CAN COME AND
I KNOW WEB THINGS THAT I REALLY
DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT BUT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL KNOW
ABOUT HEROISM AT A LEVEL THAT
WILL INSPIRE THEM.
I WILL SAY THAT.
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT PUT
THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY,
TRAINED SOLDIERS, THE BEST OF
THE BEST TO SAVE AMERICANS.
HOW DO WE POSSIBLY SAVE THEM?
DARRELL WISEMAN IS RIGHT, 500
FELLOW AMERICANS.
HOW DO WE DO THAT?
>> SEAN, I WILL TELL YOU WE HAVE
QUITE A FEW THAT WE COMPILE WITH
OUR LIST.
THERE ARE OTHER TEAMS TRYING TO
DO THE SAME THING WE ARE DOING.
MY UNDERSTANDING WAS IF GOING
BACK, THE GREAT AMERICAN ALSO
TRY TO GET OVER 100 PEOPLE.
SIX PLANES AT MAZAR-E SHARIF
WERE FULLY MANIFESTED.
SO THERE IS ZERO AND HUNDREDS OF
AMERICANS THAT STILL NEED OUR
HELP.
AGAIN, NO ONE LEFT BEHIND.
>> Sean: OKAY, WHAT ABOUT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OBSTRUCTION OF
THIS RESCUE FLIGHT FROM
AFGHANISTAN?
THEY REFUSED TO GRANT OFFICIAL
APPROVAL FOR THE EVACUATION
FLIGHTS.
I READ ABOUT GLENN BECK AND I'M
APPRECIATIVE OF HIS EFFORTS.
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO HELP HIM?
GLENN COME IF YOU ARE WATCHING,
PLEASE LET US KNOW.
I WILL DO WHAT I NEED.
AND THE OFFICIAL AUTHORIZATION
WOULD LIKELY BE NEEDED.
WHY WOULD THERE BE ANY DELAY FOR
SUCH A RESCUE MISSION, KNOWING
WHAT WE ARE DEALING WITH HERE?
>> WELCOME AGAIN, I'M NOT REALLY
SURE WHY THEY WOULD PREVENT SUCH
THINGS BUT I TELL YOU I OBSERVE
TWO WITH THESE INCIDENTS MYSELF.
WE HAD AN ACTUAL AIRCRAFT THAT
WAS FLYING IN AND PPR.
WE HAD FFA FLY OVER AND
EVERYTHING NECESSARY TO LAND
ABOUT 9,000 FEET OFF DECK,
LANDING GEAR DOWN FOR DISSENT.
WE WERE TOLD TO GO AROUND AND
THE PPR WAS DISAPPROVED.
WE WERE ABLE TO THROUGH SOME OF
THE GUYS ON OUR TEAM, DECLINED
TO PPR WHILE IN THE AIR TO GET
MORE THREE MORE PPR AND
DISAPPROVE AT WHICH POINT WE
WERE ONLY LANDING IF WE GET
APPROVAL FROM THE CHAIRMAN
MILLIE HIMSELF.
WE HAD CIRCLED FOR ABOUT
15 MINUTES IN A PATTERN AND
ASKED THE PILOT TO LAND AND
RADIO OWED AND WE WERE GOING TO
LAND.
AT THAT STAGE, THAT IS WHEN WE
WILL TAKE YOUR PILOTS LICENSE
AND YOUR AIRCRAFT CERTIFICATE
AND M-16 IN THE AIR AT THE TIME.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE INCIDENTS,
THAT AIRCRAFT ITSELF, 25
AMERICANS AND THEY SAID THE
EXCUSE WAS THE AIRCRAFT WASN'T
BIG ENOUGH.
SEAN, HERE IS THE THING.
WHEN YOU GET A PPR, A GUARANTEED
LANDING SPOT, AND A LANDING
SPOT, THAT MEANT 25 AMERICANS
THAT WE HAD AT THE GATE THAT WE
HAD READY TO GO THAT BASICALLY
HAD AN ULTIMATE METHOD AN
ALTERNATE ROUTE.
THE SECOND TIME AFTER WE MADE
THE COORDINATION'S THAT OUR TEAM
GATHERED EVERYONE UP TO THE SAFE
HOUSE AND SECURELY MOVED THEM
OVER TO MAZAR-E SHARIF, THAT IS
WHERE WE HAD AN AIRCRAFT ALREADY
ALLOCATED, AND ALREADY TWO TO
GO.
IN THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND THE
TALIBAN HAD APPROVED FOR THIS
FLIGHT TO LEAVE.
AT THE LAST MINUTE AS THE
AMERICANS READY TO GET ON, THAT
IS WHEN THE STATE DEPARTMENT
SAID NOPE, WE HAVE TO DO IT ONCE
MORE.
SINCE THEN, WE HAVEN'T HAD A
FLIGHT THAT HAS GONE OUT.
>> Sean: THAT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
TO THINK MOST AMERICANS
LISTENING CANNOT BELIEVE WHAT
THEY ARE HEARING.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT, BUT I DO
SADLY.
CORY, GODSPEED IN YOUR EFFORTS.
IF WE CAN HELP YOU IN ANY WAY OR
REACH OUT TO THE AUDIENCE FOR
HELP, IF YOU HAVE INFORMATION TO
PASS ON, WOULD YOU PLEASE DO
THAT?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY, SEAN.
AND I CAN SEE A LOT OF AMERICANS
STILL LEFT BEHIND AND MEMBERS OF
OUR TEAM ARE STILL ACTUALLY
BEING ACTIVE IN TRYING TO
SUPPORT THAT.
WE ARE ALL VOLUNTEERS.
WE ARE ALL HERE ON OUR OWN TIMES
TO TRY TO DO WHAT WE CAN.
SO COME I WOULD LOVE TO COME
BACK AND